la mayor parte de los sólidos ofrece
cierto tipo de resistencia a la
corriente que fluye por ellos y esto nos
permite definir cosas como la
resistividad o la conductividad pero lo
mismo aplica para los líquidos
consideren este contenedor lleno de
líquido y podemos medir su resistividad
si yo tomo la batería y pongo un polo
por aquí y el otro polo por acá
tendremos un voltaje y si este líquido
puede conducir electricidad esta
corriente va a poder fluir a través de
este líquido y llegar al otro lado y
regresar
algunas veces esto se hace con corriente
alterna de otra forma podemos tener
electrólisis y tendremos burbujas acá
que nos van a cambiar de cierta manera
el líquido nosotros queremos medir la
resistencia y la resistividad del
líquido no la de un líquido alterado así
que a veces se usa corriente alterna
pero este es el principio general mandar
un voltaje va a ocasionar que fluya
cierta corriente como podemos usar esto
para determinar la resistencia
sabemos que la resistividad es igual a
la resistencia que medimos multiplicada
por el área dividida entre la longitud y
aquí pueden darse cuenta que hay un
problema bueno la longitud creo que sí
la puedo calcular yo me imagino que es
esta distancia ya que me resisto entre
comillas es este líquido de acá pero
cuál será mi área este experimento no
nos serviría para calcular esto para
medir la resistividad necesitamos usar
un área bien definida así que vamos a
quitar esto e imaginemos que tenemos dos
placas tomamos estas dos placas y las
ponemos en la solución a la cual le
queremos medir la resistividad estas
placas tienen una área bien definida las
separamos a una distancia conocida que
será nuestra l y ahora si conectamos
nuestra batería tomamos esta y la
conectamos a un voltaje conocido
conectamos el otro polo a la otra placa
si esta solución electrolítica puede
conducir electricidad la corriente
fluirá de este lado hacia el otro lado y
podremos medir estas cantidades medimos
la longitud esto es fácil conocemos el
área como medimos la resistencia
bueno pues conocemos el voltaje tenemos
un voltaje conocido aquí en la batería y
podemos poner un amperímetro para medir
la corriente y ahora uso la ley de ohm
que nos dice que la resistencia es igual
al voltaje entre la corriente y si pongo
estos valores acá puedo obtener un valor
experimental de la resistividad de este
líquido
a veces se le conoce como resistividad
electrolítica o el inverso de la
resistividad electrolítica será la
conductividad electrolítica esto es la
conductividad electrolítica esa es una
forma experimental de obtenerla pero
realmente no tienen que tomarse tantas
molestias primero coloquen aquí una
solución de la cual ustedes ya conozcan
su resistividad de manera que ustedes
puedan hacer esto resistividad igual
arroz por la longitud entre el área si
conocemos la resistividad y podemos
medir fácilmente la resistencia podremos
encontrar cuál es esta constante esta no
va a cambiar por lo que dejamos las
mismas placas aquí adentro con la misma
longitud y la misma área ponemos otra
solución diferente en el contenedor y
como este número no cambia técnicamente
hablando no tendremos que hacer todas
estas mediciones del área y la longitud
cada vez que querramos calcular la
resistividad de un líquido diferente
una vez que hayamos tenido un sistema
calibrado con un líquido del cual
conozcamos su resistividad o podemos
hacerlo de otra manera si tenemos una
solución de la cual ya conocemos la
resistividad pero quizás tenga algunas
impurezas o algo así extraño en ella y
nosotros quisiéramos saber cuál es la
concentración de estas impurezas esto
nos va a afectar directamente la
cantidad de corriente que puede fluir en
este circuito por lo que va a afectar la
medición de nuestra conductividad
electrolítica si medimos esto y resulta
que es diferente de lo que esperamos de
una solución conocida podremos calcular
cuál es la concentración de impurezas
que hay en este líquido